vor knapp zwei jahren habe ich schon
einmal mit ihr an diesem tisch gesessen
mit der philosophin und publizistin
carolin inc wir haben damals du ja übers
anfangen gesprochen
nach einem jahr das vielen eher düster
vorkam möchte ich nun heute übers
aufhören sprechen und darüber was sie
uns dringend ab gewinnen sollten
und natürlich werden ja auch über
weihnachten reden das ja nicht aufhört
sondern alle jahre wieder kommt herzlich
willkommen frau in vielen dank dass ich
wieder sender svt normalerweise stelle
ich ja meine gäste vor aber ich dachte
heute gehts ja uns aufhören also höre
ich jetzt mal auf damit sehr gut hier
sagen sie doch einfach
ach so ja mein name ist caroline link
und
ich habe mit texten zu tun also ich
schreibe texte mal in kürze reform und
malen längerer form
manchmal kommen dabei texte für die
zeitung heraus und manchmal bücher genau
über diese bücher haben wir zum teil
auch sprechen
ich frage mich manchmal wenn man so
berühmt ist wie sie wie ist das
eigentlich wenn man dauernd
vorstellungen in seiner eigenen person
hört denkt man manchmal super diese
person werde ich gerne sein
also da also oder auch nicht also ich
glaube es gibt auch sozusagen so
projektionen bei den manchmal denkt oh
gott oh gott also wenn ich das wäre wäre
ja wahnsinnig anstrengend also das gibt
es auch nein ich nehme es so ein
bisschen als ein ritual und freue mich
auf den dann machen wir doch jetzt den
tag genau wir wollten
was aufhören sprechen gibt es denn etwas
wovon sie denken sie möchten dringend
damit aufhören
es gibt natürlich wahnsinnig viele dinge
über die man sich an sich selbst ärgert
schlechte gewohnheiten gegen die mir ein
beispiel
also ich habe zum beispiel die neigungen
dass ich so einzelne worte für über eine
bestimmte phase so zu lieblings worten
nicht erkoren habe über sie zu häufig
verwendet und ist dann selber manchmal
merken manchmal nicht merke und dann
nehme ich mir vor ich musste mal
irgendwie ein anderes
es wird also langweilig also sowas gibts
natürlich ich mir also klassiker müll
runter also ich sag mal so bei also
banalitäten natürlich die jetzt von uns
in der innere schweinehund jack lemmon
natürlich ich werde eine mama weniger
ungeduldig aber das ist glaube ich etwas
was man angenehmer weise von sich sagen
also ich finde ungeduldig sein klingt
noch zu gut
das ist so eine sorte von schweinehund
der ja eigentlich nach fleiß klingt also
sie müssen schon mit was um
sympathischeren daher kommen dann werde
ich denke ich muss damit aufhören ja na
gut vielleicht ist übertriebene ungeduld
dann auch seine rastlosigkeit oder etwas
was man auch zu strenge ist mit anderen
menschen ich weiß es nicht okay das ist
schon besser
na ja aber ich hinter mir ich dachte
aber sich über das aufhören nachdachte
das etwas doch interessant ist viele
leute sagen ja das war so ein
furchtbares jahr
und dann kam mir aber dieses buch ja in
die hände von guido mingels einen
schweizer journalist der heute beim
spiegel arbeitet und der hat dieses buch
hier geschrieben früher war alles
schlechter in den ja ganz viele grafiken
zusammenstellt was eigentlich alles viel
besser ist und ich wollte mal ein paar
mit ihnen angucken da gibt es einerseits
die lebenserwartung in großbritannien
zum zeitpunkt der geburt zb 1946 jahre
lebenserwartung 2011 schon 81 da denkt
man
naja wahrscheinlich ziemlich gut meisten
leute finden das gut
oder dann haben wir hier
kindersterblichkeit ist auch immer so
ein indikator wie gut oder wie schlecht
seiner gesellschaft geht das ist
allerdings nur die kindersterblichkeit
in deutschland 18 42 sind 516 von 1000
kindern gestorben
vor dem fünften jahr und 2013 nur noch
3,9 also eine drastische reduktion der
kindersterblichkeit oder das fand ich
besonders lustig die intelligenz hat
zugenommen hätte ich persönlich als
nicht so erwartet
zwar sagt der 2013 durchschnittliche iq
um 30 höher als 1909 also eine ziemliche
verbesserung der welt ist alles in
butter
na gut wir wird natürlich anders sagen
leider oder günstiger weise wie immer
man das deuten mag hängt die
verbesserung der welt natürlich nicht
einfach nur eine intelligenz also
intelligenz alleine reicht auch nicht
aus damit die welt besser wird aber
immer eines dieser beispiele heraus zu
nehmen also die frage der der
lebenserwartung und das war jetzt glaube
ich 1900 wenn ich das richtig erinnert
habe waren 40 jahre und heute sind es 81
kann man sagen natürlich na klar das ist
ein enormer fortschritt und eine enorme
verbesserung trotzdem wenn wir uns
andere zahlen anschauen würden nämlich
so etwas wie die frage wie die menschen
mit der höchsten einkommensklasse was
die für eine lebenserwartung haben und
die mit der niedrigsten einkommensklasse
in deutschland zumindest unterscheiden
die sich bei männern immerhin ich glaube
um 10,4 jahre und bei frauen glaube ich
um acht jahre also da würden wir sagen
die frage der ungleichheit ist immer
noch knapp hand also wenn es tatsächlich
zehn jahre lebenserwartung im
durchschnitt weniger sind mit denen man
rechnen kann wenn man so sagen zu den
ärmeren menschen der bevölkerung wird
dann ist das zumindest etwas bei dem man
jetzt nicht ganz zufrieden sich
zurücklehnen kann und sagen kann alles
besser geworden sei es ja auch gerade
eine neue studie von thomas rieke die
jetzt erschienen dass die ungleichheit
immer noch weiter zunimmt
ich finde auch immer interessant bei
diesen beispielen dass ich mir stets
überlegen womit vergleichen wir einfach
oder was ist sozusagen der benchmark
worauf gucken wie man kann ja einerseits
sagen na ja es ist besser geworden aber
man könnte auch sagen es ist nicht so zu
sagen so viel besser geworden wie wir
hätten verbessern können also rein die
möglichkeit wären ja vielleicht noch
weitaus besser und ein bisschen die
frage ist natürlich auch wozu führt dass
das eine ist natürlich zu sagen es hat
in der tat verbesserung der
lebensqualität gegeben es hat eine
verbesserung gegeben in dem schutz von
menschenrechten also man kann alle
möglichen beispiel nennen bei denen
medizinische verbesserung bei denen wir
sagen würden dafür kann man auch dankbar
sein und auch ja eine gewisse form von
demut haben dass man ja auch
privilegiert ist oder beschenkt ist in
so einer zeit leben zu können die so
friedlich ist oder in dem man so gesund
sein kann trotzdem betrachtet man ja
doch auch noch das was aufgaben sind und
woran man noch mitwirken oder was man
noch gestalten kann insofern finde ich
reicht der blick zurück nicht aus um ja
jetzt zufrieden und gleichgültig
sozusagen sich zurückzunehmen genau
sondern mit einigen sachen sollten wir
nämlich eben auf genau sprechen wir mal
darüber was genau schwebt ihnen davor
wenn wir uns aufhören denken sie haben
mir im vorfeld auch gesagt dass sie
finden etwas vom wichtigsten was sie
jetzt beschäftigt ist die frage wie die
eigentlich politisch dazulernen denn wir
uns überlegen was soll endlich mal weg
ja ich glaube die frage des aufhörens
ist sehr interessant weil ich glaube
zunächst einmal denkt man genauso wie
wir angefangen haben wir denken
individuell darüber nach wir denken über
schlechte gewohnheiten oder
eigenschaften die uns selber nicht
gefallen bedenken über bequemlichkeiten
oder rituale nach bei denen wir jetzt
das gefühl haben so die sollten wir
jetzt individuell endlich mal abschaffen
oder uns abgewöhnen oder damit etwas
aufhören und aber es gibt natürlich eben
auch die frage womit sollten wir
gesellschaftlich aufhören sollten wir
politisch aufhören was gibt es für
soziale fragen die wir nicht mehr
tolerieren wollen für die wir nicht mehr
immun sind und das finde ich eine
wirklich interessante frei ich finde
wirklich interessant wann in
gesellschaften oder gemeinschaften oder
auch nur nachbarschaften so eine
schwelle erreicht ist
bei dem sie sagen jetzt ist genug damit
das ist inakzeptabel dass wollen bin ich
mir wir wollen anders leben als als so
als unter dem joch von unterdrückung
wenn wir jetzt sozusagen in der
biblischen sprache sprechen würden
wir wollen anders leben als das für uns
vorgesehen ist als man uns nur zutraut
und das hat mich immer schon wirklich
tatsächlich auch bewegt dass man das
gefühl hat sehr sehr lange sind wir als
menschen in der lage schmerz oder
unglück zu akkumulieren und volieren ist
und halten sehr sehr lange sehr viel aus
wie sie sagen es reicht genau und und
das interessante ist dass ich nicht
genau benennen kann was es braucht damit
dieses eine letzte also nehmen wir das
beispiel vielleicht muss man an einem
konkreten beispiel festzumachen die
arabische revolution in tunesien das
beispiel des mannes der es in einer
bestimmten weise immer schon
mit stellen musste um die genehmigung
dass er sein gegner habe gemüsestand
waren ja haben
und im grunde genommen war es eine
alltägliche erfahrung von demütigung und
es war in an diesem speziellen tag
nichts anders als an all den tagen
vorher was hat es trotzdem genug und er
fand mit dieser form der missachtung
oder oder eben der gängelung muss
schluss sein und das war der beginn dann
tatsächlich von einer revolution
eigentlich fällt mir da auch wie war ihr
name in rosa parks seien die frau die
quasi damals ja eigentlich die ganzen
aufständigen usa losgetreten hat indem
sie in man gesagt hat und ich setze
nicht hatten bis dahin und ich stehe
nicht auf obwohl ich schwarz bin genauso
das ist genau aussagen beispiel an dem
wir sagen es ist ein moment an dem
jemand beschließt diese form von eben
rassismus oder von rassentrennung also
das so zusammen es dazu es vielleicht
erklären das beispiel also dass die die
sitze im bus reserviert waren für weiße
und schwarze mussten das sagen hinten
sitzen und sie war aufgefordert worden
aufzustehen und sich an den ihr
zugewiesenen platz zu setzen
das interessante bei rosa parks ist
allerdings das ist nicht ganz so
zufällig war dass sie diejenige waren
die da den zivilen ungehorsam geleistet
hat und gesagt hat diese praxis muss
aufhören sondern offensichtlich gab es
dort sehr viel auch politische
organisation um diese praxis
abzuschaffen man hat sehr lange überlegt
welche personen welche frau könnte das
sein
die diesen widerstand akzeptabel war
sozusagen fast inszeniert also es war
nicht inszeniert aber es gab vor ihr
auch schon an nur frauen oder auch
männer natürlich die die sich widersetzt
hatten die aber nicht getaugt haben
sozusagen um daraus eine mobilisierung
wirklich zu machen
es gab jemand wenn ich das richtig
erinnern eine frau die glaube ich allein
erziehende mutter war
ein kind außerhalb der ehe hatte und
damit war sofort klar dass die
politischen gegner das in frage stellen
könnten und wasserparks war sozusagen
eine eine person die so glaubwürdig so
integer so unanfechtbar als person war
dass dadurch auch ihr protest auch
menschen das sind berührt und getroffen
hat die vielleicht ansonsten dem wird
etwas widerständige entgegen gestanden
hätten also insofern war es ein moment
des aufhörens also zu sagen mit dieser
praxis muss schluss sein aber sie war
doch weniger individuell als als glaube
ich dass in der geschichte geschichte
erzählt wird ja jetzt wissen ja
vielleicht mal kurz überlegen was
könnten den zustände seien in dieser art
und weise jetzt aufgehört werden müssen
mir fällt da natürlich als erstes ein
dass ich denke ganz egal wie man über
die flüchtlingspolitik sprechen mag ganz
egal ob man denkt es braucht gewisse
form von grenzen oder gerade
durchlässigkeit von grenzen dass
menschen auf flüchtlingsbooten ertrinken
scheint mir einfach unmenschlich ich
finde damit sollte schluss sein aber ihr
10 wir jahres diese menschen nicht
aufstehen und aufhören sondern die
wollen weiterhin diesen weg gehen wer
müsste denn aufstehen also meine frage
ist glaube ich nach wenige müssen
eigentlich immer die opfer aufstehen
oder müssten man man auch die ringsum
sagen das reicht aber das war eine
andere form von also es ist eine sehr
sehr gute frage also ich glaube bei dem
wenn wir die zusammen die die
fluchtbewegung nehmen da muss man sagen
das ist natürlich ein so komplexes frage
wodurch die entstehen
wer dafür alles mit verantwortlich ist
dass menschen dann sozusagen ihre
herkunftsländer verlassen und wie man
mit ihnen möglichst würdig umgeht wenn
sie dann schon mal angekommen sind und
natürlich in der tat die frage dass das
elendiglich ein verrücktes und sterbens
im mittelmeer oder auch auf dem weg
dahin muss man auch sagen also auch die
bedingungen nehmen wir jetzt libyen sind
auch so dass man sagen kann das kann
niemand eigentlich darum wissen und es
aushalten also es ist unerträglich und
insofern in der tat glaube ich stellt
sich natürlich die frage des aufwands
über die fragen die sie stellen ist
richtig gefällt mir sehr gut die frage
nämlich leer muss den eigentlichen
aufstehen also wenn wir es an dem
beispiel von rosa parks nehmen
es hätte ja auch ein weißer aufstehen
können und sich nach hinten setzen oder
es hätte auch eine aufstehen können und
ihr den platz an biegen und sagen können
auch ich bin nicht einverstanden mit
dieser praxis und in der tat glaube ich
also ich kann für mich sagen ich möchte
nicht in einer gesellschaft leben in der
nur diejenigen sich wehren gegen
ungerechtigkeit oder ungleichheit oder
eine bestimmte politische praxis die von
ihr betroffen sind
ich möchte nicht also ich möchte dass
ich sage nicht dass es dazu kommt dass
nur jüdinnen und juden sich gegen
antisemitismus sind sozusagen ein
problem das es nicht ja genau sein eigen
ja und ich also ich möchte auch nicht
dass es zu sagen nur muslimen in das
selbstbestimmte recht auf das
kopftuchtragen verteidigen sondern es
müssen diejenigen verteidigen die selber
gar kein kopftuch tragen wollen ja oder
sozusagen eben gar nicht dieser
tradition angehören oder ode an die
glauben und ich glaube auch ich möchte
nicht in einer gesellschaft leben in der
nur homosexuelle das recht zu heiraten
und kinder zu adoptieren verteidigen und
das setzt natürlich eine gewisse form
von gemeinsinn voraus es setzt voraus
dass man sich auf ein gewisses
verständnis von yahoo man i tät einigen
kann und das jetzt sicherlich auch
voraus dass man ja sich auch einsetzt
für praktiken oder überzeugungen oder
glauben die einem selber vielleicht
fremd oder würde ich oder komisch
erscheinen von dem man aber trotzdem
wünschen kann dass sie existieren
ich habe mich auch gefragt waren unter
welchen umständen sozusagen ist dann das
aufstehen der opfer überhaupt
erfolgreich also eines der der der größe
oder schlagen ssten beispiele in diesem
zusammenhang scheint mir die sklaverei
zu sein
man weiß ja eigentlich dass die
sklaverei nur abgeschafft werden konnte
letztendlich nicht weil immer wieder
sklaven aufstände stattgefunden haben
die wurden brutal niedergeschlagen
sondern weiß ich dann doch irgendwann
moralische vorstellungen im zuge der
aufklärung auch durchgesetzt haben dass
so was nicht geht und es kamen
ökonomische überlegungen dazu es gab
verschiedene ökonomen die gesagt haben
das rechnet sich nichts glauben sind
nicht hinreichend motiviert zum beispiel
und das finde ich auch interessant zu
sehen wie kann sich denn eine
gesellschaft eigentlich ändern wenn es
natürlich so eine klare hierarchie gibt
also wenn diejenigen die unten sozusagen
die unterdrückten sind die opfer die
sich wehren waren immer wieder gedrückt
werden wird sich auch nichts ändern
das ist zeigen nicht es ist richtig das
glaube ich auch aber also einerseits
geht es ja schon darum dass man auch
einen gewissen anders angefangen ich
glaube es ist zunächst einmal wichtig
dass sich diejenigen die in einer
bestimmten situation sich organisiert
fühlen oder stigmatisiert fühlen oder
ausgeschlossen sind
überhaupt die möglichkeit haben zu
artikulieren insofern all diese
emanzipations bewegungen die wir kennen
und die erfolgreich waren hatten eben
auch diesen anteil derjenigen die
ausgeschlossen waren die überhaupt erst
mal ihre situation beschreiben können
mussten und die im sommer ihre
bedürfnisse ihre nöte ihre erfahrungen
beschrieben haben und ich glaube ohne
diesen anteil derer die um ihre eigene
emanzipation gerungen haben hätte es
dann auch gar keine größere
mobilisierung geben können mal das
natürlich schon auch ein wissen darum
braucht wie eigentlich die situation der
schwarzen nimmt zu zeiten der sklaverei
gewesen ist aber sie haben schon recht
das ist natürlich ein einerseits
vielleicht auch trauriger punkt das ist
das tatsächlich immer noch braucht also
das ist sozusagen die fürsprache oder
die unterstützung oder die
solidarisierung von anderen braucht um
überhaupt solche moralischen
vorstellungen durchsetzen zu können oder
politische vorstellungen durchsetzen zu
können
das stimmt schon ich glaube wenn bei
allen emanzipations bewegungen die uns
jetzt einfallen also ob es die
bürgerrechtsbewegung der schwarzen
gewesen ist ob es die geschichte der
jüdischen emanzipation in europa gegeben
gewesen ist immer hat es natürlich auch
solche stimmen gehabt die sich die
anliegen anderer zu eigen gemacht haben
und die auch begründet haben warum es im
eigenen interesse liegen kann diese
durchzusetzen
sie haben dieses buch geschrieben gegen
den hass das ist ihr letztes großes buch
und in diesem buch erzählen sie auch
unter anderem die geschichte noch einmal
von eric gegangen dem schwarzen mann das
war glaube ich zeit hat nun 14 der
staten island getötet worden ist erwürgt
worden ist und polizisten muss man sagen
er wurde sozusagen durchsucht wo kein
nicht gegen ihnen jetzt vorlag und er
hat sich dagegen gewehrt und sie betonen
sehr stark in diesem buch das er immer
wieder was sieht man in dem video
aufnahmen die man auf youtube
hochgeladen
immer wieder gesagt hat was muss jetzt
aufhören ich möchte nicht dass noch
nicht jetzt hier an fast nicht in
gewahrsam nimmt das muss jetzt aufhören
es hört aber nicht auf
ja das ist eine für mich sehr
entscheidende szene oder ein sehr
eindrückliches beispiel das glaube ich
ein wirklich gutes beispiel für das
aufhören worüber wir sprechen
ghana ist glaube ich in das kollektive
gedächtnis er dafür eingegangen dass er
eben während er so im schwitzkasten
gehalten wurde von einem polizisten vor
allem und andere polizisten auf ihn
drauf saßen hat er gesagt countries also
ich kann nicht mehr atmen und auch der
rest der genau getwittert wurde genau
was er hat wieder und wieder gesagt ja
ich kann nicht atmen ich kann nicht
atmen ich kann nicht atmen bis er eben
das bewusstsein verloren hat und dann
auch auf dem weg ins krankenhaus
verstorben ist und es ist aus diesem
letzten ausspruch ist halt so ein ganzes
slogan geworden und die blätter bewegung
hat dieses andries so als beispiel
genommen für die grausamkeit der polizei
und ich fand aber eben eigentlich die
szene die dem vorgängig ist in der noch
gar keine gewalt zu sehen ist nun der
erreger nur auf dem bürgersteig steht
und die polizei ebenso etwas behelligt
und man nicht ganz richtig weiß warum
sie eigentlich überhaupt einen verdacht
gegen ihn hegt und da sagt er diesen
satz das muss jetzt aufhören es muss
heute aufhören dieses dieses phänomen
das es eben
eine form von eben rassistisch und
profiling gibt es ist eine form von
leben permanent rassistischer
unterstellungen gegenüber schwarzen gibt
sie seien gefährlich oder bedrohlich
oder kriminell und für mich war es
wichtig an diesen satz erinnern weil
darüber auch der erreger noch mal eine
ganz andere ja auch würde bekommt dass
er nämlich das nicht mehr einfach
akzeptieren will dass er nicht mehr ist
sondern eigentlich jemand ist der sich
wer genau und auch das hat einfach diese
zuschreibung nicht akzeptieren wenn er
will nicht akzeptieren dass nur weil er
schwarz ist er permanent immer
kontrolliert und durchsucht wird und das
ist etwas was ich ja sozusagen das das
interessantere finde an der geschichte
weil dadurch er auch so eine
handlungsfähigkeit bekommt und er wird
vielmehr subjekt in der geschichte als
wenn man ihn nur über den balkan brass
erinnern und ich glaube bei dem aufhören
über das wir sprechen und das glaube ich
uns beide so ja berührt auch ist es eben
nicht nur einfach das etwas ende geht
sondern dass man mit etwas abschließen
will uns etwas anderen genau zu kommen
und um zu einer freieren oder
lebenswerteren form des miteinanders zu
kommen und ich glaube das ist die form
des aufhörens die die die interessant
ist darüber wie wir zu einer neuen
lebenswelt kommen möchte ich na ja
gleich noch einmal sprechen oder wie
diese neue lebenswelt auch aussehen
könnt also habe ich habe viel zu tun
auch mit visionen
bleiben wir noch kurz noch einmal bei
dieser frage wirklich dass das
kleinklein aufhören sie funktioniert das
denken dieses buch ist ja auch ein
plädoyer dafür dass sagen sie in diesem
buch das wir neue sehgewohnheiten
brauchen wir brauchen auch eine neue
rhetorik und das zum beispiel hat mich
sehr angesprochen weil ich einfach denke
das ist etwas was nicht unglaublich
beschäftigt dieses gebäude
beispielsweise im netz aber nicht nur
ich finde wirklich die sprache hat sich
in diesem jahr massiv
verändert zum schlechten hin das ist
etwas was ich schwierig finde
und ich frage mich dann was ändert das
denn jetzt nun wir sind beide
ausgebildete philosophinnen
wahrscheinlich beides menschen die
relativ gerne argumente haben und
empfänglich sind für argumente aber
nicht alle menschen sind sohle und wie
wie funktioniert denn das politische
lernen wenn dir einfach mal nur bei
diesem prozess nachdenken ja also ich
finde zwar das eine ist ja wenn ich das
nacheinander ja also das eine ist dass
die frage der der sehgewohnheiten und
aus der sprech gewohnheiten und dieser
ungeheuren härte und aggressivität und
sie sagen jetzt von für beleihen und
also bei uns zu hause als ich
aufgewachsen bin beispielsweise durften
sehr sehr viel dass ich durfte fernsehen
gucken ich durfte comics lesen und es
gab jetzt auch kein strenges regime
darüber was kindgerecht und was nicht
kindgerecht sein überprüfte auch keiner
aber ging nicht an
schimpfworte oder laut zu sprechen war
einfach tabu das gehört sich nicht
schlechte laune übrigens gehörte sich
auch nicht aber das war etwas strenger
bei meiner großmutter ist wenn man der
mutter aber also nur zu sagen mir ist
das erstmal anschauen ich bin
tatsächlich immer auch erschrocken
wieder gesprochen wird also weil es mich
erst noch mal erstaunt bevor es mich
entsetzt und die andere frage ist wie
geht man damit oben und und was heißt
das eigentlich für tatsächlich einen
politischen dialog und zu sagen nun
nicht alle sind zugänglich für argumente
nennen
also natürlich nicht ich auch nicht also
natürlich bin ich auch empfänglich für
eine bestimmte form der zuwendung oder
für eine bestimmte form der das erstmal
freundlichen auf
die haben nicht als person reagieren und
ich glaube das spielt da natürlich auch
eine rolle bei den auseinandersetzungen
zwischen wirklich politisch
andersdenkenden und ich glaube was mir
mindestens enorm wichtig ist zunächst
einmal unterscheiden zu können zwischen
einer person und dem was sie sagt dass
ich finde diese form des dämonisieren
des des politischen gegners oder des
anderen in dem davon pack und von mord
gesprochen würde sie also das halte ich
nicht nur finde ich zuträglich das ist
mir auch fern
ich glaube man kann ausgesprochen hat
das kritisieren was man inhaltlich
falsch findet wie sich menschen benehmen
oder was sie tun also sprechakte oder
handlungen aber deswegen kann man
trotzdem die person intakt lassen und
nicht eine person diffamieren also das
ist glaube ich ein enorm wichtiger ein
wichtiges fundament dafür dass wir
überhaupt dann noch politisch
miteinander ins gespräch kommen
ein ein anderes buch das mir
untergekommen ist was ich interessant
war war dieses mit rechten reden da
wurde jetzt auch ein viel darüber
diskutiert immer wieder und in diesem
buch sagen die autoren etwas was nicht
auch beschäftigt hat seine these die
viel vertreten worden ist aber sie wird
hier nochmal so herausgearbeitet nämlich
dass sozusagen sagen wir mal die linke
seite mit ihrem ständigen moralismus mit
dem moralisieren mit der politiker
correctness dazu beigetragen hätten
das ist diese verhärtungen gab lassen
sie so ein argument gelten also da
brauchen wahrscheinlich vier sendungen
um das irgendwie zu verhandeln also ich
finde es so zu sagen so ein bisschen
eigentümlich diese diese fragestellung
wer ist denn jetzt schuld daran dass es
so ein rechtspopulismus oder
rechtsradikalismus oder
rechtsextremismus gibt und auf einer
bestimmten ebene interessiert mich gar
nicht so sehr
wer daran schuld ist oder woher ist
kommt sondern mich interessiert was wir
jetzt machen wie es aufhört ja ja ja
nein aber auch
wie man damit umgeht und natürlich ein
bisschen ich mir immer welchen titel mit
rechten reden höre denke ich so dass es
so wie die fragestellung ob man
linkshändern die hand gibt es also
selbstverständlich habe ich gern
leitfaden ja ja nein aber es wird ja so
suggeriert suggeriert so dass das gar
nicht gemacht würde und ich würde jetzt
sagen wir haben jetzt ein jahr erlebt
oder zwei jahre erlebt in denen
natürlich beständig die ganze zeit ein
ungeheures bemühen eingesetzt hat die
motive zu verstehen die personen zu
verstehen die psychologie zu verstehen
tatsächlich auch die thesen und die und
politischen anschauungen also ich würde
mal sagen wer mit irgendjemandem viel
gesprochen worden ist dann mit rechte
ist ja auch ein sehr breites spektrum so
von denen die rechte parteien wählen
über diejenigen zu demonstrationen gehen
über diejenigen die sich wirklich
rechtsradikale organisieren über
diejenigen die publizistische verlage
haben also insofern es ist ja ein sehr
vager begriff und also ich würde jetzt
erst mal sagen es ist nun wirklich auch
von von medialer seite aus wenn mit
irgendjemandem viel gesprochen worden
ist dann mit all den verschiedenen
szenen und milieus die sozusagen unter
diesem begriff vielleicht fallen könnten
und ja ich habe das buch gar nicht so
sehr gelesen das ist eine frage ist eben
soll man mit rechen reden war
selbstverständlich soll man die sind in
einer demokratie wir müssen uns
miteinander verständigen
aber gerade wenn es darum geht die frage
zu stellen wie hören wir auf mit
gewissen dingen müssen ja erst einmal
überhaupt eine gemeinsame verständigung
über die interessante frage ist doch
also wenn wir jetzt nicht einfach nur
von wählerinnen und wählern also sondern
wenn wir jetzt wirklich von demjenigen
sprechen die politisch organisiert sind
die klare politische agenda und auch ein
klares programm haben dass man es ja
auch lesen und sozusagen
studieren kann dann würde ich ihnen
schon glaube ich muss man sich natürlich
fragen ist denn überhaupt ein
verständigung sorry n tierte
kommunikation erwünscht
oder ist das nur strategische
kommunikation was da betrieben wird also
ich glaube dass schwieriger also sagen
wir so ich für mich würde immer sagen
selbstverständlich interessieren uns
gespräche in denen es dissens geben kann
in denen es eine verständigung geben
kann in denen man über kompromisse
nachdenken kann aber auch in denen man
vielleicht grenzen dessen feststellt und
benennen kann die man überhaupt
verhandelbar findet also ich glaube
schon es gibt bestimmte fragen es gibt
bestimmte ethische fragen bestimmte
juristische fragen bei denen ich sagen
woher die sind nicht verhandelbar also
es gibt auch bestimmte wahrheitsfrage
ich würde jetzt nicht glauben dass wir
allen ernstes noch verhandeln sollten ob
die erde eine scheibe ist oder ob sie
rund ist also um sowas zu sagen und ich
finde schon dass das ja wenn man
tatsächlich darüber nachdenkt wie man
sich verständigen kann muss kann man
auch schauen will der andere das
überhaupt will der sich mit jemandem wie
mir verständigen
oder geht es bei dem gespräch nur an
darum vorzuführen dass man teil eines
diskurses geworden ist und darin
irgendwie auch einen normalen legitimen
anspruch auf öffentliche repräsentanzen
kann und da bin ich nicht immer ganz
sicher ob das wirklich der fall ist
da fällt mir ein anderes bild ein
nämlich gar dama dama hat man gesagt
verstehen ist horizont verschmelzung und
ich fand dieses spiel immer so schön und
vielleicht könnte man ja sagen naja und
politisches gespräch aber auch ein
persönliches gespräch muss aber stehen
orientiert sein sonst ist es kein
gespräch sonst ist es eben ein gebrüll
oder einen unterstellen oder nur
manipulativ also auch dass die riskant
also wenn wir uns sozusagen klassische
theorie kommunikativen handelns
anschauen würden wir sagen da ist
wahrhaftig kann
eine bedingung für die möglichkeit eines
gelingenden gesprächs man kann nicht mit
jemandem sprechen der permanent einfach
nur eine überzeugung behauptet die er
selber gar nicht hegt oder sozusagen
eine verfassungstreue behauptet die sie
selber gar nicht hegt insofern
wahrhaftigkeit spielt schon auch eine
rolle und das was sie sagen natürlich
überhaupt überhaupt so gleichwertig in
ein gespräch hineinzugehen und auch
tatsächlich interesse an an den
überlegungen und ideen des anderen zu
haben und nicht nur daran in irgendeiner
weise manipulativ ein gespräch zu
gewinnen oder sich zu zeigen und alles
anderes bisschen dann natürlich auch ja
mutwillig finde ich es ein mutwilliges
umgehen mit sprache und begriffen und
auch dem was einen dialog sein kann wenn
man ihn eigentlich gar nicht wirklich
ernst meint da bin ich völlig einig
bedienen wenn wir noch mal das bild
neben der horizont verschmelzung damit
dass gerade so er durch den kopf geht
was mir daran glaube ich gefällt ist
dass ich als ein hohlraum braucht also
sie ist jetzt nichts geht nicht darum
dass wir unsere welten verschmelzen
sondern unsere horizonte und das zeigt
ja auch dass man im gespräch im blick in
die zukunft sich entwirft und dass man
sich überlegt wie geht es denn weiter
und da hat mir eine kolumne von ihnen
unglaublich gut gefallen sie haben
nämlich in einer kolumne sie schreiben
ja kolumnen für die süddeutsche noch
nicht kennt oder und da haben sie mal
geschrieben ihnen fehlt das einhorn
hafte in der politik habe habe ich
deswegen so gefallen hatte ich nie
verstanden habe warum eigentlich überall
ständig einhörner sie gar nicht erklären
wenn die kamera aus
wieso es würde jetzt gerne eigentlich
sagen das kann ich mir das erkläre gut
aber wir möchten jetzt gerne darüber
sprechen
das einhorn haft in der politik dass es
scheint ja darum zu gehen woraufhin
entwerfen wir uns unterscheiden die
relativ waren profillos unterwegs zu
sein
ja also im moment glaube ich ist das
eine der
großen schwierigkeiten ich glaube wir
erleben zurzeit eine phase in der wir
sehr sehr viel demokratischen
willensbildung erleben also menschen
artikulieren ihren zorn und ihre wut und
ja ihre ihr unbehagen und manche anteile
daran finde ich sehr verständlich und
finde ich auch sehr sehr nachvollziehbar
und begründbar und glaube ich auch sind
in einer bestimmten weise auch gesund in
der demokratie also dieses dass man auch
in unbehagen empfinden kann ein soziales
unbehagen oder ein politisches unbehagen
insofern glaube ich sollte man das gar
nicht so leicht diskreditieren oder
abweisen
aber es gibt natürlich auch eine anteil
der einfach nur destruktiv ist und der
sich hinter sozusagen dem begriff des
der sorge verbirgt und eigentlich
einfach nur ressentiments und hass
schürt und davon erleben wir zurzeit
sehr sehr viel so diese und
willensbildung und wir erleben extrem
wenig demokratische willensbildung und
zwar fürchte ich dass es auch damit zu
tun hat dass man zurzeit gar nicht mehr
sicher sagen kann an welchen orten
demokratische willensbildung eigentlich
stadt hat also ich habe lieber weise
eine weile lang wirklich geglaubt hat
natürlich mit dem arabischen frühling
auch zu tun dass soziale medien ein
instrument wären über das sich eben auch
demokratische willen formieren kann und
über über dass sich politische
subjektivität herstellen kann müssen wir
alle sagen das ist entzaubert waren
diese hoffnung und im moment erleben wir
soziale medien vornehmlich als
beschleuniger von japan von hass und von
von ressentiments und ich glaube wir
sind zurzeit alle ein bisschen auf der
suche an welchen orten und über welche
mittel demokratische willensbildung
stattfinden kann und ich darf das ja
gerne in der schweiz sagen wenn ich noch
ein satz dazu sagen darf ich denke weil
das würde ich so gerne in der schweiz
aber sagen ich glaube ja dass das
öffentlich rechtliche fernsehen
einer der orte ist an dem diese sorte
von selbstverständigung diskursen stadt
haben kann den jede demokratie braucht
ja das ist glaube ich wie es sind wie
die kapillaren durch die das dass das
oder durch die diana durch die das blut
dann auch pumpen kann dass eine
demokratische gesellschaft braucht und
über die sich dann sehnsüchte entwickeln
kann visionen entwickeln können
vorstellungen entwickeln können wie wir
denn eigentlich leben können und es
können natürlich medien insgesamt
liefern ja und die frage ist dann wie
man die medien organisiert also das ist
der ist natürlich im moment gerade eine
große debatte in der schweiz nie wusste
aus organisiert sein
aber wenn mir vielleicht noch einmal zum
einhorn zurück sie möchten dass ein raum
ich möchte gerne was eine aktive möchte
ich darüber sprechen
die kommen ja eigentlich zu neuen
visionen weil ich sage ja wirklich ist
stimmt das eigentlich ich mag mich gut
erinnern habermas hat 1985 diesen
aufsatz geschrieben die neue
unübersichtlichkeit und da hat er gesagt
die visionären energien die sind
aufgezehrt und eigentlich muss man sagen
naja hat sich gewaltig geirrt
also wir haben glaube ich damals nehme
ich jetzt mal an keine idee davon das
ist ein mauerfall geben wird dass es so
etwas geben wird wie das eine so große
macht wie deutschland den atomausstieg
entscheidet oder dass man das internet
finden wir sie also es sind ganz viele
dinge passiert aber trotzdem glaube ich
habe man so ein bisschen den eindruck
eben diese visionären energien wo sind
die eigentlich wo wollen wir eigentlich
hin
ja also wir können ja immer sagen dass
ich das spricht ja schon komme jemand
von fortschritt ja aber wenn wir das
sagen sagen mal gesellschaftlicher
fortschritt oder emanzipatorischer
fortschritt oder sozialer fortschritt
braucht vielleicht auf der einen seite
tatsächlich sie haben jetzt nicht per
zufall das internet genannt also
natürlich braucht es auch bestimmte
innovationen die im wissenschaftlichen
bereich oder im technischen bereich
liegen wenn wir uns die geschichte
anschauen können wir immer auf die
geschichte erzählen anhand von welchen
wissenschaftlichen entdeckungen oder
erfindungen hat sich dann auch eine
soziale mobilisierung oder eine große
soziale veränderungen ergeben
und natürlich legen wir mit der
digitalisierung genau eine solche
tiefgreifende veränderung und
gleichzeitig braucht es aber eben auch
übersetzungen in politische und soziale
sprachen und visionen und ich glaube in
der tat also speziell deutschland würde
ich sagen hat in der regierungszeit
angela merkel dienen natürlich nichts
mehr scheut als eine vision
man hat das gefühl angela merkel
betreibt politik eigentlich immer auf
sozusagen gerade sichtweite merkt man
übrigens auch an der sprache also es
gibt kaum eine formulierung von angela
merkel in der es wirklich nur
möglichkeiten oder konjunktive
perspektiven geht sondern es ist
sozusagen ein ungeheurer pragmatismus
daran und ich glaube auch dass das zum
teil eine erklärungen ist für dieses
empfinden von heimatlosigkeit von
menschen oder das empfinden von allein
gelassen sein das sind ja nicht einfach
nur ökonomische sorgen oder nöte die
sich da artikulieren sondern ich glaube
das sind auch fragen nach ja sich
irgendwo zugehörig fühlen sich irgendwo
aufgehoben fühlen die sich im moment
sehr sehr häufig in nationalismen
übersetzen aber ich glaube es hat auch
was mit einer politischen fähigkeit zur
vision zu tun oder mit einer politischen
fähigkeit von vokabular ian und
begriffen und bildern in denen sich
menschen tatsächlich angesprochen und
aufgehoben fühlen und ich glaube dass
der nationalismus dann gar nicht die
antwort sein kann die
dieses unbehagen wirklich abdeckt das
ist alles total interessant mit 1000
bürgern den kopf man kann ja sagen es
gibt so was wie die sogenannten neuen
konservativen die genau das versuchen
sie die sehnsucht nach heimat den neuen
nationalismus segen die auch zusammen zu
bringen um zu sagen wir müssen uns
verteidigen wir müssen auch das
verteidigen was uns letztlich ausmacht
und da fällt mir sloterdijk auch noch
ein der dieses buch die kinder deren die
schrecklichen kinder der neuzeit glaube
ich heißt das buch da sagte er wir
brauchen rituale wir brauchen unbedingt
auch geschichten die uns verbinden weil
nur das garantiert eigentlich so was wie
zivilisation wenn das wegbricht dann
sind ja gar niemand mehr und können das
was uns ausmacht nicht verteidigen
ja also ich bin jetzt kein großer
nein ich wollte erst wenn jetzt gar
nicht gut er hat sechs zu kommentieren
sondern ich die frage ist doch ob wir ob
wir in einer demokratie ist sozusagen in
der lage sind erzählungen zu finden
sprache zu finden bilder zu finden in
denen erstens menschen sich
wiedererkennen können und zwar alle und
nicht nur ein bestimmter teil ja dass
wir erzählungen finden die sozusagen
einerseits seien offen genug sind dass
sich viele in ihnen wieder erkennen
können und angesprochen fühlen und die
gleichzeitig aber auch so eine dynamik
entwickeln dass sie die hoffnungen
machen können
dass sie ängste nehmen können und ich
glaube die angebote die es im moment
gibt die angeblich die ängste und die
sorgen adressieren sollen vermitteln
kein gefühl weder vermitteln sie ein
gefühl von tatsächlicher zugehörigkeit
noch vermitteln sie das allen und
insofern ist es glaube ich eine wirklich
wirklich große aufgabe eine kleine eine
eine vision zu entwickeln in denen
sozusagen das unwahrscheinliche platz
hat das ist für mich das einhorn ist um
auf ihr einhorn noch mal wieder
zurückzukommen und in denen sozusagen
eine politische utopie eine politische
sehnsucht wieder sich artikulieren kann
ich glaube das ist es dann mit dem fall
der mauer und bin 89 hat man so ein
bisschen so getan als ob das nachdenken
über politische visionen auch ad acta
gelegt werden könnte und das kann nicht
ad acta gelegt werden einerseits weil es
da zu viel zu große herausforderungen
gibt ob es die globalisierung ist ob die
digitalisierung ist und weil die frage
inwiefern das sind einzelne menschen
oder einzelnen regionen darin platz
haben so dass sie mit gestalten können
dass sie partizipieren kann dass sie
sich zugehörig fühlen in dieser
dynamischen welt darauf müssen wir
antworten nach vorne geben und nicht
antworten nach hinten ja jetzt habe ich
den eindruck eigentlich sind wir an
einem punkt wo die zwei wege offen
stehen auf der einen seite können wir
darüber sprechen oder haben jetzt
darüber gesprochen was für neue visionen
könnten hier entwerfen was für ein
höherer die nicht nur partikulare
einhörner sind für eine gruppe sondern
ein horizont abgeben der sozusagen als
schirm über allen aber wir haben auch
darüber gesprochen dass es gemeinsame
geschichten braucht auf die wir uns
berufen
das heißt man könnte eigentlich auch
sagen auch rituale auch mythen könnten
elemente sein und aufhören zu schaffen
weil man sich nämlich auf das beste
konzentriert was wir sein können ein
absolut ich glaube sozusagen all diese
politischen fragen die frage
so seien politische sehnsüchte
artikulieren zu können geht
selbstverständlich mit der frage an hier
was in schulen an erzählungen vermittelt
wird welche sorten von geschichten
vermittelt werden inwiefern sich das
curriculum der kanon in den schulen in
den theatern in den filmen in denen ja
in den geschichten in denen wir uns
wiedererkennen können auch öffnet und
gleichzeitig vertieft also ich glaube in
der tat dass es erzählungen vor allem
fiktionale erzählungen eine sehr viel
größere emotionale kraft haben als jetzt
so dass es bücher wie man ihn ja beneide
auch immer leute die ihn im theater
geschichten erzählen könnte den film
erzählen können aber dann müssen wir uns
auch tatsächlich befragen welche
literatur lesen wir denn eigentlich in
den schulen in der schweiz oder in
österreich oder in deutschland und wie
stark haben denn tatsächlich diese
schulstunden schon eine solche vielfalt
in sich wie sie sie in den kindern die
dort in der schule sitzen repräsentiert
sehen und da würde ich sagen ist
wirklich noch luft nach oben davon wie
stark europa erzählt und bebildert wird
in den schulen noch mal ganz zu
schweigen also auch das findet ja meiner
ansicht nach viel zu wenig statt dass
wir wirklich portugiesische literatur
italienische literatur polnische
literatur in den schulen als eine
selbstverständliche ressource wahrnehmen
um verstehen zu können wer wir sind und
es hängt natürlich steht und fällt immer
mit der frage wer unter wir alles
einsortiert wird genau und die frage
auch immer welche geschichte darf nur
noch erzählen und welche geschichte
grenzt aus und heute ist ja heiligabend
eine geschichte die wir dann natürlich
immer erzählen ist die lehre die wir
beide mit sicherheit gut kennen ja
schauen sie mal ich habe hier meine
krippenfiguren mitgebracht und haben
sich als auch in der kindheit stammen
haben sie in hesel ottobeurer
ich habe nur das rudimentäre eingepackt
aber die sind schon total vertraut von
wachs die hatten die schon als kinder
ehrlich gesagt glaube ich die stammen
noch von viel früher ja aber es ist
jetzt eine sehr rudimentäre version
würde ich mal sagen weil natürlich nicht
aber der ist schon da
da geht es sie haben jetzt zum beispiel
schon die heiligen drei könige nicht
dabei ja ja also das würde natürlich die
geschichte schon etwas dichter und sagen
migrationshintergrund ich habe sogar an
den migrationshintergrund gedacht aber
ich meine wir sagen dass jetzt immer so
ironisch um damit vermeintlicher weise
uns lustig zu machen oder sie sich
lustig zu machen über diese art des
sprechens mit dem migrationshintergrund
aber wenn wir jetzt ernsthaft an
weihnachten tatsächlich man hat über die
biblischen geschichten reden wollen dann
ist flucht und vertreibung nun wirklich
zentrales motiv vom alten testament bis
ins neue testament hinein also die
geschichte von moses also übrigens auch
die frage was familie eigentlich ist
groß es ist ein waisenkind es gibt in
den biblischen geschichten wenn wir
jetzt sagen wir nehmen erzählungen ernst
und wir glauben dass diese erzählungen
uns auch heute noch etwas sagen können
was ich zum beispiel glaube dann würde
ich sagen muss man sie auch wirklich
lesen und wenn man sie wirklich liest
bergen sie eben eine ungeheure vielfalt
an personen eine ungeheure vielfalt an
ja umgang mit dem was das fremde ist
umgang mit dem was flucht und neu
ankunft was exil heißt und edv armut
bedeutet was übrigen armut bedeutet was
es bedeutet ausgeschlossen zu sein nicht
erwünscht zu sein und wir haben immer
wieder auch geschichten von figuren und
familien die irgend jemanden aufnehmen
der zunächst einmal die zunächst immer
nicht zu ihnen
hört es gibt eine ganze anzahl von
widerständigen figuren auch aber eben
auch figuren die dann ein ganzes volk
anführen die nicht unbedingt aus diesem
volk vielleicht stammen
insofern würde ich sagen ja ich bin
unbedingt dafür dass wir an diese
geschichte erinnern
und dass sie auch heute noch kraft
spendet und dass sie auch heute noch
ja diesen reichtum uns aufhört aber
natürlich können wir auch geschichten an
der griechischen mythologie erinnern wir
können auch jüdische geschichte wieder
eskalierende die interessante frage wenn
jetzt wohin diese idee hatten dass
rituale gemeinsame geschichten uns als
gemeinschaft stärken können wenn es die
richtigen geschichten sind auch
inkludieren können also seid machen
können
kann ja die frage welche geschichten
wählen das ist doch gar nicht öffnen
kann mir sondern die frage ist doch ob
ich war mir eine geschichte immer von
kindheit an erzählt worden ist und weil
ich also ich es tatsächlich also kann
ich sehr sehr viel in den bezügen und
bildern und metaphern dieser alten
geschichten noch denke ob ich deswegen
erkenne dass menschen die eine andere
geschichte von kindheit an erzählt
bekommen haben
genauso in ihrer geschichte hängen die
frage ist doch immer was vergleiche ich
eigentlich und ich glaube der gedanken
fehler ist den inhalt der geschichte zu
vergleichen und sich dann als in kommen
so rabl zu verstehen aber ich kann doch
einfach mich vergleichen dazu ob jemand
überhaupt an geschichten hängt ob jemand
überhaupt damit oft also es kann auch
jemand an ist in der es muss jetzt gar
keine religiöse geschichte sein also es
kann auch jemand anja anderen texten
literatur hängen also ich will das gar
nicht im moment das möchte ich jetzt
gerne besser verstehen weil ich nicht
sicher bin ob ich ihn davon würde
wir stellen fest dass wir beide witze
mögen zahlen diese methoden wir merken
wir mögen beide witze ja und das kann
irgendwie verbinden ja
aber es ist doch nicht dasselbe wie
werden wir über den gleichen witz lachen
natürlich nicht natürlich also das war
so in denen lehrer ist doch über den
gleichen witz zu lachen es ja es ist
eine bestimmte weise verbinden aber im
moment ist doch die diskussion die ganze
zeit so als ob es sich komplett
ausschließen würde im moment ist das
interessante das verschiedenheit in
irgendeiner weise automatisch als
bedrohung gedacht wird ja es wird
verschiedenheit nicht als eine variante
von vielen möglichen varianten gedacht
und ich kann das kann ich einfach
überhaupt nicht verständlich kann gar
nicht verstehen warum ich nicht mit
einer bestimmten geschichte oder meiner
geschichte wie auch immer so sahen die
glauben kann an die praktiken glauben
kann oder oder die auch zu praktizieren
kann und gleichzeitig sehen kann dass
jemand eine andere geschichte hat und
die mit bestimmten ritualen einhergeht
mit einem bestimmten feiertag mit einem
bestimmten essen das dann gekocht wird
mit bestimmten kerzen die dann
angezündet werden und und und und er
nichts daran dass jemand anders einen
anderen glauben als ich praktiziert oder
an etwas anderes glaubt oder in einer
anderen lebensformen sich besinnt wir
müssen es gar nicht so stark auf die
religiosität glaube ich fest machen
beeinträchtigt doch meine das wäre ein
wirklich das wäre wirklich schwach
verwurzelt also wenn allein die tatsache
dass jemand etwas anderes also wir haben
ja sagen sie erzählen echt wirklich die
allerschlechtesten witze auf der welt
sagt sogar ich erst sagen wenn wirklich
alle sind echt überhaupt nicht meine
witze aber wenigstens hat simon finde
ich jetzt definitiv besser als wenn sie
gar keinen hätten und insofern glaube
ich es ist eine wirkliche beschädigung
glaube ich unseres öffentlichen
sprechens über religiöse täten oder über
herkunft oder über lebensformen ist dass
wir permanent immer unterstellen dass
jemand der in irgendeiner weise sich
unterscheidet von mir
meine eigene identität verunsichern
würde also nicht schlecht also ich weiß
zum beispiel sie sind auch ein großer
fußballfan ich jetzt zum beispiel nicht
so bin aber sie können ihr dankeschön
sie können ihr fußballfan tun ja nur aus
leben wenn es hinreichend andere
fußballfans noch gibt und es gibt doch
das phänomen dass menschen die etwas
ganz toll finden und sich sehr stark
damit identifizieren eben von den
eindruck haben ihr ritual geht flöten
wenn ein ritual auch darin besteht dass
andere stylen und ihre haut verstehen
durch an justin worüber man lacht wie
das genau funktioniert wirklich noch so
ein bisschen sagen wir leben einfach
schon seit jahrtausenden nicht in einer
welt in der alle denen wir begegnen die
exakt selben witze sich erzählen
geschichten sich erzählen oder ein
großteil das hat es noch nie gegeben das
ist einfach so sagen dass es mich dass
uns ein zauber ja aber das gab es nie es
gab nie eine so sagen so monokultur ganz
egal wo sich aufgewachsen sind sie
werden immer irgendwann jemandem
begegnen der anderes essen mag andere
geschichten erinnert jetzt mal ganz
abgesehen von denjenigen die sozusagen
sich alle auf diese geschichte heute
beziehen gibt es eine riesige varianz
also das ist was was jetzt sie haben ist
das fußball haben sie vor dem eigentlich
gesagt nein aber wenn wir das ich bin
jetzt das spiel musik liebhaberin und
das ist etwas was man wirklich wirklich
aus der musik natürlich lernen dass eine
tradition oder eben ein musikstück leben
und existieren kann und dadurch
bereichert wird das ist immer wieder
neue interpretation zu dem kern text
oder dem kernstück gibt und so ist das
mit jeder tradition
niemand der heute sozusagen unbedingt
dass seine eigene identität meint
dadurch verteidigen zu können dass er
sich auf eine angeblich gefährdete
tradition beruft beruft sich darauf das
selbe wie der nachbar nebendran der sich
auf dieselbe weise ruft also von daher
würde ich immer sagen
die kunst ist doch einerseits sozusagen
sich artikulieren zu können ihn ja den
bezügen und den sinn stiftenden bezügen
den kulturellen oder religiösen bezügen
in denen man sich aufgehoben fühlt und
verstanden fühlt und gleichzeitig so zu
sagen so offen zu bleiben dass man weiß
dass es für andere andere bezüge gibt
und die mich nicht anfechten
verlieren sie weihnachten ja ja ich
meine sie main mit sie wollen jetzt die
wollen jetzt alle rituale wissen also
was ist dieses krise fall sonst absolut
richtig ist aber auch übrigens eine
interessante feststellung warum es in
die rituale eigentlich indiskret oder
die befragung von ritualen das stimmt ja
auch wiederum nicht für alle
ich glaube ich dass es vielleicht auch
eine der schwierigkeiten das sozusagen
die gesellschaftliche rituale die sind
ja überhaupt nicht hat ja nichts
indiskrete voran das kennt jeder aber
die art und weise wie man sich aufs
ritual bezieht das hat etwas
unglaublichen teams ja das ist
interessant und ich muss jetzt zugeben
dass ich früher gar nicht darauf
gekommen wäre dass die frage nach
frömmigkeit oder religiösen praktiken
eigentlich in das also was in diskretes
hat oder was intimes hatte und bissig
mal bei einer öffentlichen veranstaltung
wohlig moderierte jemanden neben mir
gefragt habe also inwieweit sozusagen
der der muslimische glaube eigentlich
eine rolle für sie spielte und dann hat
die gesagt das ist aber eine intime
frage und und dann war ich so sehr ein
bisschen erstaunt und hab gedacht
ja das stimmt
vielleicht auch eigentlich dass man
selber ja gar nicht absehen kann wie
ernsthaft es jemandem ist mit dem
glauben und der vergänglichkeit insofern
für manche menschen ist das überhaupt
keine indiskrete frage und für manche
menschen ist es aber eine sehr intime
frage genau das ist aber auch wiederum
interessant halte ich nämlich gar nicht
meint er ich dachte nur in die sowas
sind sie ein mensch der oder die rituale
der weihnachten kennt ist das für sie so
ein familien leider sogar toren und
selbstverständlich dass ein museum
erinnert an also musik ist ja also sei
also sagen wir mal so ich bin jetzt
schon religiös musikalisch und ich bin
auch noch musikalisch und ja es gibt
rituale aber natürlich jeder mensch der
rituale schätzt oder pflegt durchbricht
sie oder füllt sie anders auf als es die
eltern oder großeltern gemacht
das ist absolut richtig frau empfehle
ich ihnen frohe weihnachten sehr viele
gespräche ich bin auch ganz herzlichen
dank
jetzt hören wir nicht auf sondern wir
machen gleich weiter und zwar mit einem
film über einen radikalen neuanfang der
ware oktober erzählt die russische
revolution von 1917 aus der sicht von
künstlerinnen und künstlern in einer
woche ist silvester ich boxe hatten dich
empfangen sie zu einem philosophischen
jahresrückblick wir haben in unserer
schatzkiste gewühlt und die schönsten
momente aus unseren sternstunden für sie
zusammengestellt jetzt aber auch in zwei
festtage und aufwand
[Musik]